well if Washington finally decides to
fix the country's immigration problem
mark Morgan will be at the very heart of
that you've known from this show he's
been a frequent guest we've happened to
have him every time he's been on and
he's now the president's new pick to run
ice mark Morgan joins us tonight for his
first interview since starting the job
mr. Morgan thank you very much first of
all congratulations thank you on the new
job and thanks for joining us
what's what are your priorities well
first and foremost I think anyone in
this position is to make sure that I'm
gonna be a relentless advocate for the
men and women of ice to get the tools
necessary to do their job and part of
what that means also is getting out here
doing what I'm doing right now to
educate the American people exactly what
the hard-working men and women of ice do
every day to safeguard the security of
this country and enforce the rule of law
and also working with Congress but
here's here's the problem with that
Tucker Congress has clearly showed its
inability to do what they know they need
to do to fix this crisis and I've been
on there many times and saying they
could do several things within a legal
framework that could fix this in 15
minutes so although I'm going to
continue to work tirelessly with
Congress to try to get them to do their
job I don't have hope that they're going
to so we need to continue to come up
with innovative ideas within the legal
framework we can to stop this problem
well they've completely politicized your
agency completely absolutely moving into
the heat of an election season a number
of the candidates have called for
getting rid of ice completely have
compared you to the Nazis absolutely
really over-the-top stuff so given your
expectation that they're not going to
help at all what can you do so I'll give
you an example right now so ice actually
has three major components that American
people and I unfortunately think a lot
of Congress don't even realize so they
have the ero side that's the enforcement
and removal operations it Deportes
people they also have an incredible team
of lawyers that's an integral part of
the overall immigration process that's
absolutely needed and then the last part
of ice is HSI Homeland Security
Investigations and I'll give you an
example so those three major components
makeup ice HSI for example what we've
done is we've taken about 150 highly
trained experienced HHS HSI agents and
we push them towards the board
and what they're doing is they're
looking at Child Exploitation they're
looking at those individuals who are
grabbing renting the kid right and we
called this Tucker we knew this was
gonna happen and it is they are renting
kids they're paying to rent somebody's
kid and then fake themselves as a family
and right now between and we've infused
the DNA testing that we've talked about
in the past so between their
investigative skills and the DNA testing
right now in the pilot program they're
finding 25% of the so-called families
come across absolutely fake fraudulent
just the other day they caught a 51 year
old man from Honduras
guess who he had with him as a family a
six month old and because the work that
HSI they found out to be completely
false that's the kind of stuff that
we're doing and we need to continue to
do what would happen if we got rid of
ice exactly so right now ice on the ero
side this this year so far just the
first quarter 66,000 individuals have
been deported of the the rest that
they've made sixty five percent of those
arrests were actually people with
additional criminal convictions ninety
percent of those either had a criminal
conviction or a pending charge you get
rid of ice think about that so sixty six
thousand not deported you have a just an
incredible amount of people who are
doing bad things they could remain in
the United States on the HSI component
last year alone thirty four thousand
arrests Tucker thirty four thousand
criminal arrests four thousand five
thousand gangs human trafficking cases
Child Exploitation cases 1.2 billion in
currency they seized the list goes on
and on and on so when you have somebody
that puts out the reckless irresponsible
rhetoric about ice being abolished
that's what's gonna happen this country
will absolutely be less safe because of
how its demented I don't think there's
any popular support for I've never seen
a poll that says most voters yeah let's
get rid of ice good idea absolutely get
rid of the FBI along along with it so
quickly if if Congress just in a dream
world was willing to help you okay if
Democrats were on the same page in
protecting Americans borders what's the
first thing you would ask them for two
things they have to adjust the legal
rough framework right now there's two
major things they have to fix the Flores
settlement agreement which mandates you
can't hold a family more than 20 days
then plus TV PR
and that's the trial child trafficking
Protection Act right that says that if
you're from Mexico or Canada we get to
send you back but if you're from the
northern triangles countries we can't
those two things equal catch and release
Congress can fix those two things in 15
minutes the second thing is they
absolutely need to continue to increase
the funding for ice specifically on the
detention bed space it's just common
it's common sense Tucker they don't care
but you do care and I don't know a
single person disagrees you are the
right man for this job
thank you joining us tonight absolutely
thank you see